the parents of a Penn State student who
died in a hazing incident last year say
they've reached a settlement with their
son's fraternity 19 year-old Timothy
Piazza suffered head and abdominal
injuries after an alcohol fueled hazing
ritual his family settlement with the
Beta Theta Pi fraternity mandates a
number of reforms they include requiring
all chapters nationwide to be alcohol
free by 2020 an attorney representing
the Piazza family said the reforms are
to make fraternities safer all of this
is to try to push forward something good
that can come out of something that was
so horrible and something so tragic the
settlement was for an undisclosed amount
it still allows the parents to move
forward with claims against individuals
25 defendants still face charges
connected with Piazza's death we've you
know spoken with the Piazza parents who
liked it very much
there are wonderful people and they have
dedicated their lives to making sure
this does not happen to another child
they're seeking real reforms I know it's
not the money or anything they want
things to change it's their life and
they're making a difference difference